first tonight though like every night we
want to start with facts that will help
you and your family stay safe and secure
without the fear hysteria and panic that
others are peddling clearly the US
response to this pandemic is unlike
anything we have ever witnessed or ever
seen and today the president invoked
what is known as the defense production
act now this is a move that will
massively ramp up the production and the
distribution of very important medical
supplies ventilators respirators this
will include five hundred million new
n95 masks the president also dispatched
earlier today to Navy hospital shifts
one to the East Coast one to the West
Coast and the Pentagon is now preparing
mobile medical units to be deployed all
over the country as they are needed if
they are needed meanwhile America's
brilliant medical researchers scientists
doctors health care workers they have
been working around the clock as usual
not just on a vaccine but also
treatments that will mitigate or even
prevent the contraction of the virus or
the effects of the virus if you do get
it hours ago the president gave us a
little preview of what we can expect
tomorrow this is getting interesting
take a look tomorrow we're having a what
I think will be a very interesting news
conference and I think you know what
that's all about
so we'll see the FDA will be they've
been working very very hard and I
appreciate what they're doing and I
think we have some very interesting
things that will be brought up tomorrow
at the news conference it'll be set up
by thinking around 11 o'clock or so but
we look forward to seeing you tomorrow
there's a pretty exciting news our
medical a-team is here tonight we're
going to examine what what the
possibilities are here there are now
multiple antiviral medications being
studied many have been tested one that
was previously used against the bola one
anti-malaria medication developed
decades ago showing a lot of promise it
has been used in the course of this
particular corona virus outbreak and of
course we do expect in the short term
that the confirmed cases will
dramatically increase we've been
preparing you for that but again if we
all follow the rules
out by the president's task force and
not that difficult we're gonna be
helping every American especially the
most vulnerable the elderly with
underlying medical conditions
compromised immune systems in the
meantime we look forward to the coming
announcement from the president and the
FDA tomorrow without a doubt we're the
greatest country on Earth
got to remember that yes we will get
through this we've been through a lot of
tough times and we always prevail and as
the president tweeted tonight strong
United yeah will prevail moments ago he
posted this message to the American
people let's take a look I want to thank
all Americans for pulling together for
coming together for doing what they have
to do it's been incredible it's been
inspirational all over the world they're
watching and of course you've heard it a
thousand times
wash your hands good hygiene all of that
but social distancing keep away it's
gonna have no place to go and I just
want to thank you as president I want to
thank you for the incredible job you're
all doing this spirit in our country
like never before we are really we've
pulled together as a unit we pulled
together as a country we will prevail
together we love the USA this is an
all-hands-on-deck moment and we're
seeing the greatness of the American
people on display every day in every
level once we beat back the virus China
must be held accountable their hostile
government cares more about optics than
the lives of not only their own citizens
but the world community this massive
cover-up in the critical early stages of
this disease frankly unforgivable it is
an indisputable fact that China lied
people all over the world suffering and
dying as a result of these lies Axios
recently put together what is a
comprehensive timeline that you need to
see we'll start on December 10 2019 last
year that's when one of the first known
coronavirus patients becomes ill then on
December 27th Wuhan health officials
determined a new type of corona virus
was spreading three days later on social
media top director at the Wuhan central
hospital tried to warn the public about
this dangerous new disease and how it
was spreading from person to person she
was subsequently reprimanded and
uncensored then on January first eight
other doctors who posted him from
about the disease online were called in
for questioning
also censored in January seventh the
president of China became directly
involved in the response January 11th
the Wuhan Health Commission insisted
there were no new cases which we now
know as a blatant lie January 14th World
Health Organization at this late date
tweeting quote Chinese authorities have
found no clear evidence of
human-to-human transmission of the virus
really and get this four days later
China hosted its annual Lunar New Year
banquet guess we're in the city of Wuhan
and that province were tens of thousands
of people gathered for a potluck supper
was it until January 20th the China
admitted the disease can spread from
person to person the first person that
we know had corona in America arrived on
January the 21st ten days later the
president's travel ban the single best
decision made to date by any country it
gave us time save countless thousands of
Americans from contracting the virus and
likely many deaths now by the way at
that point it was too late
Colvin 19 had already spread to South
Korea a day later the first case
confirmed here that's the 21st I was
just talking about probably already
multiple cases in Italy which we now had
discovered had direct flights from Wuhan
that province and a large Chinese
population working in their textile
industry for weeks China could have
sounded the alarm
instead they lied they tried to cover it
up and they had massive potluck
celebrations at the epicenter of this
disease and now China's government now
they're spreading baseless conspiracy
theories blaming the US military for the
spread of the disease they're even
proliferating an insane talking point
that uses the using the word China or
Wuhan virus to describe the Wuhan virus
is racist and of course many social
justice warriors and the media Mob
particularly concern that much about
health no they want political
correctness even at a time like this
unwittingly echoing what is a Chinese
propaganda talking point take a look hi
the others have criticized you for using
the phrase Chinese virus
how do you feel about after you get to
continue using that friend something
really exciting using that phrase crates
of stigma why do you keep calling this
the Chinese virus there are reports of
dozens of incidents of bias against
Chinese Americans in this country why
are you keep using this letter comes
injury exists you do have people in the
asian-american community whose lives are
at risk and for the president to call it
a Chinese virus or a foreign virus that
is just not it's just so dangerous and
not a good thing to do this is a virus
that came from the territory of China
but came from bats this is a bat virus
not a China virus it doesn't speak
Chinese and today the President had a
clear message for those who seem more
worried about identity politics than
actual truth take a look that's not
racist at all no not at all it comes
from China
that's why comes from China I want to be
accurate I have a great I have great
love for all of the people from our
country but as you know China tried to
say at one point maybe this stuff now
that it was caused by American soldiers
that can't happen it's not gonna happen
not as long as I'm president it comes
from China times of uncertainty facts do
matter this virus did start in China the
Wuhan province and it's not the first
disease to be named after a location for
example Ebola that's named after a river
river in Africa and there's a Spanish
flu and then the Middle Eastern
respiratory system known as mares and we
can go on and on ultimately the facts
are clear the Chinese government tried
to cover it up recently they kicked out
all American I have to say so-called cuz
I don't exactly trust fake news the New
York Times Washington Post Wall Street
Journal but I do want them there and now
because of China's actions thousands
around the world are dead millions
others are suffering and China must be
held accountable